In the collective memory of the People Diana,
Princess of Wales was everything rolls should be.
She was beautiful,
composed and full of compassion for those in need,
and when did she died?
In 1997.
It was a horrific tragedy that shook the world.
She had been robbed of a future that was looking incredibly bright and our sons
would forever be without a mother,
but the dark secrets of Diana's life proved this.
All that glitters is not gold.
Some people believe that her death was no accidents and there was actually an
elaborate conspiracy designed by the royal family to silence in the biographics
video today we look at Diana Princess of Wales.
Dan was born on July the first 19,
61 to John and Francis Spencer.
It had been a tradition for members of the inability to marry one another for
centuries and her parents were no exception.
Together with her two older sisters and two brothers,
they lived in a mansion called Park House in north England.
As you can imagine,
Diana grew up with the best things that money could buy and she went on play
dates with children in the royal family,
but all of the money in the world can't buy happiness drawn in Francis.
They had a toxic marriage mold her life.
His parents never said,
I love you to one another or indeed to their children.
They pushed off most of the parental duties.
Do Nannies or governesses at age nine,
her father sent her to boarding school.
Her mother remarried to a man called Peter Shand kid,
who was the ad who is successful wallpaper company.
Her father married a woman named rain mccorquodale,
who was the daughter of a famous romance novelist.
The children,
they weren't present at their second fall,
this marriage,
and they have to find out about it through the newspaper.
Diana to siblings deeply resented rain as an evil stepmother and blames half a,
tearing the family apart.
Diana was a shy girl and she struggled in school.
She was labeled as the thick one by her family and this was enough for her to
ends up crying in school.
Every time she got a bad grade,
deep down,
all she really wanted was to be loved and accepted for who she was and dreamed
of a prince who was going to take her away so she could live happily ever after.
When she was just 16 years old,
Diana met Charles the Prince of Wales for the first time.
He was 29 and dating her older sister Sarah.
The relationship between Sarah and Charles,
it never went anywhere,
so they went their separate ways.
However,
Charles said that Diana made a big impression on him because he thought she was
very cheerful and beautiful when she came of age.
Diane,
I could have chosen to party like a socialite or travel the world with a family
as well,
but when she was eating,
she chose the very normal life of working as a kindergarten teacher.
She used her paychecks to Sharon apartment with a few friends that I loved
taking care of children,
and it made her very happy to give them the love and the encouragement that she
never got as a little girl at that time,
Diana was filled with a lot of hope about our future.
She said that she felt this deep sense of destiny and one day she would grow up
to do great things.
Prince Charles had been dating several women over the years,
including Camilla,
Rosemary Shan's.
Camilla was not wife material in the eyes of the Queen,
so she married a multimillionaire named Andrew Parker Bowles.
Charles and Camilla never actually broken off that relationship and they
continued having a secret affair the entire time that she was married.
Charles was now in his thirties and under lots of pressure from his mouth as he
settled down and produce an APP,
he needed a wife that was a member of the aristocracy and Diana had all of the
qualifications of a perfectly acceptable bright off going on.
Only 13 dates.
Charles proposed to Diana when she was a belly legal 18 year old,
even though they hardly knew one another to nfl,
says the becoming the princess was the sense of destiny that she had been
waiting for all along a couple of weeks after their engagement.
The couple was interviewed by the press.
Towards the end of the reporters said that they were very much in love.
Dan replied,
of course,
Charles Loft saying whatever in love means watching the tape.
You can clearly see that Diana was heartbreaking and later interviews,
Diana defines that instance,
is the moment she knew that marrying him would be a huge mistake.
However,
the entire world had their eyes on her and she knew it was her duty to go
through with the marriage.
Even to this day diner and Charles still go down in history for having one of
the most expensive weddings.
Experts estimate that today that wedding would cost anywhere from 70 to
$100,000,000.
From the perspective of the people watching the wedding on tv,
it seems like a dream come true.
Diana later said it was the West staff.
My life.
The honeymoon was on the royalty entrepeur Tanya,
Diane,
and reportedly spent most of the time sleeping in 1982.
Charles and Diana had been married for less than a year and she had already
discovered Charles is secret relationship with Camilla Parker Bowles.
He started to gaslight her saying that she was paranoid.
This made half so devastated that she threatened to kill herself.
Joel is ignored her and started to leave to go on a horseback trip.
Diana threw herself down the stairs.
The Queen rushed our aid screaming for a doctor while will love the attendance
around at the princess.
Joel's just kept on walking to the outside world.
The marriage between Diana and Charles seemed like a fairytale that comes to
life for the first time.
People around the world were fascinated and invested in the royal couple.
The Massa,
what was going on behind closed doors.
She had to smile,
wave and just pretend that everything was fine.
Diana was still just a teenager when she was put under pressure by the media to
be this perfect princess combined with a healthy marriage.
It was enough to make a spiral into a deep depression and she became.
She had so much empathy for other people.
That's a particularly difficult meeting,
visiting the pole sick and we Beta mental health a lot worse.
Instead of recognizing that she needed help,
Diana was treated like a child throwing a Tantrum and the royal family just
continued to ignore her issues.
William was born when Diana was 20 years old,
just barely out to that teenage years.
She was to raise the future king that's a William Reuter loss of joy and purpose
to our life during interviews.
That press would mostly ignore how while they spoke with Charles,
asked Diana how the baby was doing,
even though this was actually very demeaning to Diana's face,
would light up and she would gush about how much fun she was having with him.
Even officer giving birth to the.
Our relationship with our husbands remains coles and distance.
She eventually decided that if she was going to be stuck in an unfaithful
marriage,
she would have an effect too.
When she was 23,
Donna fell in love with a cavalry officer named James Hewitt.
They went together about a year before how second some Harry was born in
pictures showing the two of them side by side.
It is easy why people believe that James Hewitt might actually be Prince Harry's
biological father.
This is such a popular theory that it was even turned into a stage play that was
performed on the west end.
Diana pushed Charles to be more involved in raising the boys instead of relying
totally on Nannies.
When the boys were old enough to go out,
she made sure they had normal experiences like waterparks,
Mcdonald's,
and shopping.
She also brought them to homeless shelters to pass out hot tea and food.
Prince Charles,
he scoffed at these ideas and asking why all of that was necessary when she was
25.
Diana fell in love with her bodyguards.
Barry Maliki.
They became best friends and she felt very safe around him.
April's lots of joy to our life,
but Diana claims that they never actually crossed the line.
However,
most people still consider this to be an emotional affair or at the very least,
once their friendship was revealed.
Prince Charles Five Medicaid,
no long enough to anything.
His job at the royal palace sparing anarchy was killed in a motorcycle accident.
Charles and Diana were on their way to the con film festival in France when he
told her the news.
Charles mentioned many death so casually.
It was as if he was talking about the weather.
Diana wanted to cry there.
She knew that within a few moments you would have to step out of the car and to
be photographed by hundreds of people,
so she had to put on that smile once again and just pretend like nothing was
wrong.
She and I just said,
I think he was bumped off,
but we'll never know.
Diana felt that if she did not escape the marriage,
she really might want to take her own life.
She knew that her only hope of getting a divorce would be to get the public on
her side.
It was at this point that she decided to speak with a journalist named Andrew
Morton about the truth of the dysfunctional household motion.
Eventually published her biography called a Diana.
Her true story in her own words,
for the first time in history,
the public got a glimpse into the life of a royal marriage,
says certainly wasn't prissy.
Charles responded by being interviewed for a documentary in 1994 called trials
the private man,
the public role where he admitted he had an affair with Camilla,
Parker Bowles.
Lana responded by doing an interview on BBC Panorama in 1995.
During this interview,
she said that she believed Charles was not a good person and he wasn't even fit
to become the next king of the United Kingdom.
She believed that her son,
William would do a much better job serving the people Diana said of herself that
she wouldn't go quietly saying that's the problem.
I'll fight to the end.
Diana and Charles were separated for years and seeing other people off to the
bickering back and forth in the media.
The Queen herself demanded that they needed to officially get divorced.
In 1995,
Diana began dating and Egyptian millionaire named dirty Fiat is falling though
was the owner of these successful Harrods department store runs,
has the net worth of one point $6,000,000,000,
which by the way is far richer than the queen.
Charles and Diana were officially divorced in 1996.
Jobs would eventually go on to marry his longtime girlfriend is going to the
pocket bowls even after leaving.
Her position is Princess of Wales at wanted to continue her destiny by making a
difference to the world.
She was pretty terrible at public speaking,
which really was necessary during charity events and public appearances,
so she started to receive vocal lessons from a former actor named Peter
settlement during the lesson settled and set up a camera to record her progress
and you asked her questions about her personal life.
These became much needed therapy sessions for her.
She revealed secrets about her marriage and the royal family through these
lessons with sas alone,
and she was able to find her own voice and learn to thrive as a public speaker
after her death.
These tapes were confiscated by the royal family and the public were not able to
see them until years later.
Diana,
she became a traditional celebrity without the benefit of royal security.
The you continued to follow her and write about her in the tabloids.
Instead of allowing the press do you only write about her hair and fashion
choices,
she decided to make the best of being in the spotlight by getting involved in
causes that matter tat she raised awareness about the aids epidemic and travel
to several African countries to fight for the ends of landmines and public
spaces.
One of the most famous photographs of her was with a young amputee who had had a
leg blown off almost immediately after getting the attention of the press,
the laws,
amount,
landmines.
They were changed.
However,
this was making lots of politicians unhappy.
They said that she was getting involved in issues that she didn't fully
understand how response was that she really didn't care she was going to fight
for the people and not the politicians instead of wilting into quite obscure.
He,
Diana,
she was thriving.
She was no longer depressed.
She was glad to trade her title for a life of freedom.
She auctioned off all of our designer gowns and gave millions to charities that
she cared about all of this,
and you made the public love her more and she was still a princess in the hearts
of the people.
Often her divorce was finalized.
Diana was dating an Egyptian man named doody fired.
He was a multimillionaire.
He lived a very glamorous life,
pepper add,
see took photos of them on vacations around the world,
the British press schools in a playboy and write negative connotations about the
fact that he was Muslim.
He was actually a successful movie producer who was best known for the Oscar
winning movie starring Robin Williams.
It was also the RTD multibillion dollar Harrods department store.
Fortunate.
The two of them were very much in love and they plans on Sunday getting married.
Some even believe that Diana may have been pregnant with his child.
If this was true,
it would have cost a lot of issues for the royal family.
The idea that William and Harry,
you could have a Muslim half sibling.
It was unacceptable.
She was also threatening to reveal more and more secrets about the royal family
to the press or charity work as well.
It often interfered with money making schemes among the inability indeed she
even received death threats on a regular basis.
Not long before her death.
Diana wrote a letter to a Butler saying that she believed her ex husband Charles
was trying to have are killed in a car accident.
She also cold duties.
Father Mohammed all fire engines told him the same thing.
On August the 31st 1997 dirty Fiat and Diana were being driven through Paris on
that named Henri poll,
just as they entered the alma tunnel.
They were apparently running from pepper,
etsy and ended up in an accident.
For whatever reason,
every single one of the security cameras inside the tunnel just so happens not
to be working that day.
So there is no recording showing exactly what happens.
According to witnesses,
the car went into a pole at 65 miles per hour and no one was wearing a seatbelt.
On September the sixth,
19,
97.
The streets of London where lines with people moaning,
Princess Diana's death.
Millions do.
You didn't watch the funeral procession on TV.
They're all cortel to trial and found that the crash was simply an accident.
However,
everyone present at that trial was obligated,
decide with the royal family and that findings.
Many people think they were totally biased.
However,
in 1999,
the French government also investigated the car crash and they came to the same
conclusion.
It was simply an accident.
However,
in 2008 and new independent investigation found that the driver Henri Pool had
been drinking heavily that day and the original trial had failed to mention that
they also concluded pepper add,
see vehicles.
In fact,
tailgating the calm,
the jury concluded that Henri Paul was responsible for the deaths and that if he
was still alive,
he would be convicted of meme set.
For some,
this investigation was not enough and one of those people was Dodi's.
Father Mohammed are fired.
He had spent years of his life struggling with racism while running his
business,
and he was disgusted by how the media is portraying Dodi,
even though he was a victim to Mohammad.
All five claims that he had evidence for 175 separate conspiracy theories and
paid for a documentary called unlawful killing to cover them all.
Obviously in this video we call him go too deep into all of the conspiracy
theories,
but it was enough for the British government to ban the documentary from being
seen in the United Kingdom.
According to these conspiracy theories,
Henri Paul was actually sober that day because the receipts from the hotel
showed that he only had two drinks at dinner and had gone through a medical exam
by security beforehand.
He had actually outrun the pepper ratzy and mysterious wide Fiat,
you know,
followed them into the tunnel with a group of motorcycles.
Some believe that these were on my six agents who were being paid by the
government to kill her.
After inspecting the cola,
they discovered that the seatbelts and honorary pols car had been tampered with,
which is why no one was wearing them.
It also took over an hour and a half for the ambulance to get to the hospital
even though they were very doctors,
believe that if Diana was wearing his seat and into gotten medical attention
sooner,
she would've survived.
Unfortunately,
without videotape of the crash,
we may never know the whole truth of the circumstances surrounding her death
today,
Princess Diana,
she's not truly gone because she lives on in Prince William and Prince Harry's
legacy because of her.
They both do charitable work and they married for love instead of finding a mate
inside of the royal family,
and we're sure that if she could see them today,
she would truly be proud.
So I hope you found this video interesting.
If you did,
please do hit that.
Thumbs up below and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos just like this twice a week,
so hit that subscribe button and you'll learn all about those when they come
out.
And as always,
thank you for watching.